on est prêt ce qu'on attend d'elle n'a
ce n'est pas la finale et la coupe ça va
être très chaud très chaud on est là bas
si on est la maman a pris car on est là
[Musique]
j'ai raté mon avion et je leur pays
encore 1000 euros et pour pour venir ici
au quai à regarder le match tellement
l'algérie est allée elle est là
[Musique]
le premier sacre c'était en 1997 de
l'année de ma naissance
saleh après 29 ans une autre finale
pourquoi pas une autre course
blanc c'est que le peuple est derrière
nous et il le prouve encore ça pour nous
c'est que de la force et des algériens
qui viennent des quatre coins du monde
et algérie surtout en quartiers on va
créer toutes les chances
les conditions pour le serrer les rangs
pour cette poule pour le sénégal pour ce
trophée pour la première fois
mais se pressera nous sommes très
concentrés nous savons que nous avons
des arguments à faire valoir
c'est en finale qu'on va j'ai dans
l'allégresse de calmants parce qu'on
sait qu'on va gagner cette finale à nous
avons de très bons joueurs
nous avons un collectif fort des
résultats vont permettre au sénégal de
remporter ce premier trophée continental
offrir aux 6 millions de sénégalais qui
en abaissant le sénégal amènera le coup
le coupe d'afrique wine challenge la
prochaine année on amène ici le coupe du
monde charles